well uh we've got we've got another
story here queued up uh the doj is going
to sue Texas over Governor Abbott's
floating wall and razor wire along the
Rio Grande
the justice department notified Texas
that it plans to file a lawsuit over the
latest tactic in operation Lone Star
Governor Greg Abbott's controversial
border security initiative a legal
challenge welcomed by Abbott tpr
confirmed on Friday that the justice
department sent a letter to Abbott's
office outlining that Abbott's floating
border barrier in the Rio Grande
violates federal law raises humanitarian
concerns and is a threat to Public
Safety and the environment okay so they
don't mention the fentanyl coming in
from yeah exactly they don't mention the
tens of thousands of children left
unaccounted for uh at the border who who
yeah I mean when you want to talk about
a press release
can't get everything in Sheamus well and
I'd like to ask you this because you do
know the law not to put you on the spot
if you don't know the specifics of this
that's fine but I'm curious if you think
there's really a case here I don't one
of the limited duties of government is
to deal with immigration federal
government is not doing that if anybody
should be suing anybody Texas ought to
be suing the amen amen uh that's why we
just have to ship more bus loads up to
these blue States and then maybe the
else I heard with the with the mayor of
New York just now said we've had too
many no that's right we're no longer a
sanctuary cities and then I said imagine
I said imagine no borders yeah I said
imagine no countries why don't you let
them in no religion too this is so if
you this is one of my one of my favorite
facts of American politics that has
become far more clear over the past uh
few years but when you place left-wing
people in the circumstances that
conservatives have been in for decades
they magically have this Epiphany and
begin to develop conservative
perspectives part of what was so
strategically brilliant about these
Governors and border states shipping
yeah shipping uh these these migrants
off to
blue States is they forced them to make
our arguments there's too many people we
can't support everyone who wants to
enter this country we don't have the
resources to take care of them okay if
you in New York City don't have the
resources to take care of these people
what about a poor Border Town in Texas
are you on your mind yeah you know there
was a study done by the Civil Rights
Commission some years ago and the group
most hurt by illegal aliens uh are black
and brown people living in the inner
city those with high school list
education because virtually all of the
illegal aliens have very little
education there are about a million
fewer blacks who are working because of
the presence of illegal alien labor and
the presence of illegal alien labor puts
downward pressure to the tune of almost
two thousand dollars per year on the
salaries of people living in the inner
city yeah so once again the people who
are most likely to vote Democrat the
ones that left claims that they care
about black and brown people are the
ones most hurt yeah exactly it's crazy
to me that uh text or the doj is upset
because Greg Abbott says hey we're gonna
put up a barrier here because you're not
supposed to enter illegally and by the
way swimming across the Rio Grande is
incredibly dangerous so we should not be
incentivizing it as a way for people to
enter this country illegally anyways but
that doesn't matter right it's a
humanitarian crisis that uh that Greg
Abbott is standing in the way of floods
of illegal immigrations which apparently
Democrat parties benefit from and it and
I think you're totally right to bring up
the fact that they uh
continuously fail to advertise the cost
and who is truly impacted by this I have
said over and over again that not only
are illegal immigrants themselves
especially people who are trafficked
across the border abuse and hurt in the
process but also every Community every
person affected by this pays a price
that when we say but it's just mean you
can't put a wall there you can't put
floating buoys in the water
Democrats used to agree with you I put
on my uh my website uh a montage I did
some years ago of Bill Clinton uh uh
Barack Obama
um Dianne Feinstein Chuck Schumer all
talking about the Damage Done by
unfairly illegal immigration uh Harry
Reid even used the the word illegal
alien and it was a book they all used to
say this and then they did a 180 when
they realized that the votes were were
among Hispanics and they figured that at
some point by letting a bunch of illegal
aliens in to be enough pressure to put
on to make them uh residents and then
citizens and then they would vote vote
Democrat if legal aliens turn residents
turned voters would vote Republican we
would not be having this conversation
well and not only that but when they go
to places that tend to vote blue they uh
artificially inflate representation
there the pollsters say there are more
people there so that they have to you
know increase their seats but I also
want to mention this horrible horrible
term you used illegal alien don't you
know that the preferred term is friend
we haven't made yet
is true because uh they point that out
about Cuban immigrants and people who
come over from Cuba that who they know
have a tendency not to vote in the same
way because they came from a socialist
country and so they don't play to that
demographic the same way they do those
at the Texas border wasn't there I I
might be misremembering but there was
this wet foot dry foot policy that
actually made it more difficult for
people who entered the nation uh on
wraps basically uh you know people who
came from Cuba to enter that's kind of
interesting yeah yeah there's a complete
bisor and what what I find uh like just
totally disturbing is I mean first off
we have to acknowledge that Greg Abbott
responds with Texas has the sovereignty
to enforce border security yeah and I
have to you know you can criticize Greg
app for a lot of things but I I really
like that he has made this a priority
for his administration I like that he is
willing to make bold choices
um again with the bus saying everyone
can accuse him of theatrics I think it's
good I think everyone should be aware of
what's going on and you know one of the
strangest things happened to me since I
began working conserved media is I think
Instagram figured it out even though my
Instagram is very you know just personal
and not political at all uh it started
sending me videos that some of the
Border Chiefs take and post on their
social media platforms and the just
obvious traffic that goes through that
area the obvious destruction that comes
through is uh something that I wish more
people talked about I didn't seek that
out Instagram has identified me as a
conservative they have figured it out
but it is interesting to me that you
won't see that that reality portrait I
mean the obvious case of this is uh with
the the group of Haitian migrants who
are under the bridge and trying to cross
and um and Alexander mayorka reprimanded
the border patrol officers who are on
Horseback saying they whipped them they
did the same and they didn't they didn't
they got proofed against it and mayor
orcas is still in office letting our
border policy continue and also not
standing by the agents who are doing
their best given the limited resources
that they have considering the federal
government consistently undermines
states that are trying to be proactive
like Texas and the difference between
Democrats that I assembled in that
Montage were complaining about legal
immigration 20 years ago and now the
average illegal immigrant coming from
the southern border was a Mexican on
foot coming across the border now 100 of
them pretty much have are paying cartels
yeah well and not not only that not only
that the investment has been taken over
by the cartel the majority of people who
are being trafficked across the border
are not Mexican I was having a
conversation with Jenny Tara about this
who's a reporter and journalist an
actual one who who's gone down to the
Border several times what she told me is
that this is her she said she has not
spoken to a single Mexican the entire
time she's been down there now I
understand that that's anecdotal that's
the experience of one journalist but
statistically the majority of them are
not from Mexico no I was going to point
out our own show I'm going to cite
ourselves citing the Los Angeles Times
uh when the fourth bus of migrants
arrived in La this week from Texas the
majority were from Venezuela this is not
fair to anyone which is weird because
socialism is great I thought we loved
socialism I can't no one can explain it
well they're here to evangelize about
social they listen to the Imagine song
over there they heard it yeah yeah no I
mean I just think that immigration is
one of these issues that I'm so glad
that more people are talking about
because again it's the the fact that the
doj looks at Texas putting up a floating
buoy while the kind that you would see
like if you were swimming at a lake and
they're saying don't go too far uh
they're super racist that they are
trying to deter people from illegally
entering the country which by the way
they are risking their lives they're
being put into horrible situational
doing the humanitarian crisis is Texas
trying to stop this and not the idea
that anyone is willing to take children
and do this take this journey is is
crazy when Biden got elected ABC's
Martha raddatz interview with this guy
who just come across the border and she
said to him would you have tried this if
president Trump had gotten reelected he
said no of course not
shocked she said really she said
so she was shocked the guy who's not
going to try this are you kidding yeah
of course not one of the people respond
to incentives people when the laws are
being enforced people are less likely to
break them is that wild one of the
statistics that uh Republicans quote a
lot especially when uh Andy Briggs uh
Biggs entered the motion to uh uh
impeach majorcus a little bit earlier
this year one of the statistics comes up
is the number of people who are on the
FBI's most wanted list who are
apprehended at the border and they're
saying there are more people apprehended
at the border on the fa most wanted list
under Biden and that sounds a little
weird like I don't know better job of
catching them no it's because under
Trump they didn't come near the border
that's right it's like there's way more
this is way more they do things like
this those are those the ones they
caught exactly they also do things where
they'll say like oh Barack Obama
actually stopped more people from
crossing the border than Bush did that's
not true they just redefined what it
meant to stop somebody at the border
under the Obama Administration sure and
they had uh what was it title 42 where
there were all sorts of issues uh with
related to covet that we ended up
terminating because the bite
Administration took away and then had to
put it back I mean mean I think the the
immigration issue is just profound it
really affects our country I I was
wondering if you want to talk a little
bit more about your stance yeah
potential president uh are you are you
looking to restrict any legal
immigration I would put back the Trump
policies that gave us the most secure
border we've ever had uh the stay in
Mexico policy I would stop catching
release I would apprehend and uh and put
in confinement to people who are
crossing the border illegally because
that's the only way you can Deport them
once you put them in the interior
they're going to stay forever yeah
um but yeah we we need temporary workers
if they're truly temporary uh and there
are some high skilled uh workers that we
that we need but we should determine the
number the amount and how long they stay
so can I ask you something just related
not necessarily to Illegal immigration
but your own policies what what would be
your administration's priority what's
the first thing that you would do if you
were elected first thing I would do uh
is to stop this war on oil and gas allow
drilling on federal properties and I
would uh finish the wall and uh again
reverse the anti-trump policies that
Biden has implemented those are the
first couple things I would do thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time